thanks Sarah Jane you're with the daily
climate show for the next 10 minutes
coming up
New Zealand's government has proposed
taxing animal burps as part of a plan to
cut methane emissions
the football industry takes action
against climate change we ask if players
are doing enough to reduce the game's
carbon footprint
and why lemurs are spending less time in
trees
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis but first we're starting in New
Zealand where the government there say
it's one of their biggest environmental
problems
cows but it's more to it than that
farmers there are set to be charged for
their greenhouse gas emissions including
methane belches out of the cattle it's
the first of its kind in the world and
the government there say it's their plan
for putting a price on the climate cost
of farming
all money raised from charges on
emissions will be recycled back into the
system to fund further research tools
and Technology as well as Pharma
incentives in order to help reduce
emissions all revenue will go back into
those goals
well Sky's eye shirt zahid joins me now
big pledges from the governments in New
Zealand you've been taking a look at
some of the numbers that's absolutely
right and the reason it's so important
is first of all New Zealand has a
population of around 5 million people
but double the number of cats or 10
million and 26 million sheep as well and
it when it comes to their greenhouse gas
emissions half of them come from these
farm animals that's things like methane
nitrous oxide so they're trying to meet
pledges that they've met and if we look
take a look through some of those pages
first of all at cop 26 New Zealand
pledged to join it was a global pledge
to reduce methane emissions by 30 from
2020 Levels by the next decade on top of
that the country is also committed to
reducing methane emissions by 10 by 2030
as well and by up to 47 by 2050 so
delivering on This Global methane pledge
is estimated to reduce warming by about
0.2 degrees Celsius so really important
to them to make these changes but of
course it's come with opposition first
for a major Lobby group for the industry
there saying that this would rip guts
out of small town New Zealand and of
course there's um the government
opposition also protesting they're
saying that if anything it will just
mean that farming moves elsewhere and it
will end up contributing to worldwide
emissions too so yet to see what they
decide to do at the moment of course
it's only a proposal okay Aisha thank
you very much time to take a look at
some of the day's other climate news for
you now a new research suggests there
would be Millions fewer UK Birds by the
middle of the century if the government
backtracked on green brexit farming
subsidies conservationists fear that a
review of the 2.4 billion pounds pledge
would cut vital parts of the schemes are
designed to help improve habitats on
farms or the green Alliance estimates
that bird populations would fall by over
2 million if the scheme was scrapped
now more than a third of hoverflies
which are a key pollinator of crops are
under threat of Extinction in Europe
according to new research now the
international Union for conservation of
nature found 37 of hoverflies in Europe
are critically endangered endangered or
vulnerable to Extinction now the main
threats are from intensive Agriculture
and pesticides to the loss of ancient
trees and of course climate change
Downy study has found that Rising
temperatures and the thinning out of
habitats is leaving the already
endangered Lima populations of
Madagascar at greater risk so scientists
found that the hotter it got the longer
they spent on the ground and
deforestation forces them to travel out
into the open between trees well
research suggests that not so all lemurs
will be able to adapt this way leaving
them potentially more vulnerable
now when we think about the industries
that are acting when it comes to climate
change football doesn't necessarily
spring to mind footballers are more
Associated I guess with private jets and
lavage Lifestyles than climate activism
but the number of football clubs being
affected by the impacts of global
warming is increasing and now football
is looking towards how they can be parts
of the solution instead of adding to the
problem of a global football industry
admits about 30 million tons of carbon
dioxide every year about the same as a
small nation such as Denmark or Tunisia
everyone loves to have their teams
latest shirt but football fashion
generates 750
000 tons of waste a year across Europe
but without action the game itself from
Grassroots to professional level is
under threat 25 of English football
league stadiums are at risk of annual
flooding by 2050 due to sea level rises
and extreme weather events caused by by
climate change and it's not just England
the German Olympic Committee said floods
that killed hundreds last year also
caused more than 100 million euros worth
of damage to Grassroots Sports
infrastructure
well Sky Sports presenter David Guido
joins me now he's been looking at
football's impact on climate change
thanks for joining us David no problem I
suppose the first question is we now
realize the impact football is having on
the climate but it's an issue I suppose
that the industry has brought on itself
you know they've fly clubs around even
during the transfer window you know you
have to go from office to office someone
has to drive you there yeah that's right
I think if you looked at Global Sports
as a whole and compared it to a country
in terms of carbon footprint the
ambitious estimates towards something
like Spain or Poland so it does have a
huge impact and obviously football's the
the major part of that is followed by
3.5 billion people across the world and
there are some incredibly unsustainable
practices within the game but what's
interesting is that the major bodies are
starting to recognize this and they are
starting to move down the funnel towards
a more environmentally friendly future
and way of being way of thinking no it's
interesting you should say that what are
the governing bodies doing what are some
of of the players doing because it's a
big issue that lots of people want to
get behind now well UEFA of course uh
have the Champions League they have you
know the the governing body of European
football they're looking at expanding
this tournament however what they're
saying instead in terms of reducing
their comfort print is they're talking
to all of their National associations
and saying you have to have
sustainability manager you have to have
a sustainability ethos and really
mandating that and imposing that there's
so much encouragement you can do but
they've got a more direct route and they
say look yeah sometimes we have to do
other things that aren't particularly
environmentally friendly but we are
making these small steps and hopefully
that can bring the rest of the crowd
along and fashion and sustainability in
the football industry is such a big
thing isn't it it's absolutely huge and
we reveal in the documentary some of the
really starting statistics about fashion
footballs Fashions footprint but there
are clubs doing some great work here
football you know have for example
foreskin Rovers who is the leading Club
in terms of sustainability they have a
shirt that's made out of coffee grounds
and recycled parsley bottles which which
is just Mega um there are others who are
for example choosing not to renew their
shirts
um you know the next season and produce
a new version Brent for example keeping
their shirt from from last season so
there are definitely impacts there that
can be felt and and progress that is
being made but I think what's important
is that they're just at the moment
they're female examples there needs to
be more and there will be more we sense
that there is really growth in this area
because the interesting thing that you
discover is if things don't change there
will be big problems 25 of English clubs
could be flooded yeah that's right so
the research that has been done in this
area suggests that a quarter of English
Premier League and football grounds
that's a good sort of
22-23 clubs could be underwater or
regularly flooded annually which is so
so hard to even compute that these
stadiums could be underwater then you
think about training grounds then you
think about recreational football you
know just simply a kick about on a
weekend or a Sunday afternoon that's
what you know is going to be really
really badly felt because you know if
you don't have the way to adapt and
mitigate these things then you know that
Grassroots level is going to be severely
impacted so there really is an incentive
there and an urgency to the situation
too okay David thank you very much for
joining us to talk about the documentary
we appreciate it well that's all from us
on the daily climate show back now to
Sarah Jane